si vous l'avez oublié un petit peu la
comédienne maintenant jouer il faut chez
un rôle c'est à dire oublier très peu
pour passer à la femme
vous avez été très gentils vous aimez
permis de venir dans votre appartement
voir comment vous viviez et nous allons
voir aucune réflexion si vous voulez
tout ça vous à skis protection ça vous a
donné jusqu'à reportage de jacques
gérard cornu
le voici alice sapritch chez elle
à l'est sap richesse que vous êtes
souvent chez vous comme ça dans votre
appartement dans notre position dans ce
bon fauteuil fume-cigarette herman l'a
souvent ce m'arrive assez souvent et
j'aime beaucoup parce que c'est
c'est ici que j'aime je travaille je
rêvasse je pense à des tas de choses
est ce que c'est une chose importante
pour un appartement ce que vous avez
conçu d'une façon particulière non je
n'ai pas conçus d'une façon particulière
pour moi un appartement c'est un endroit
où je dois être bien vous voyez c'est un
appartement agréable qui est simple je
pense qu'ils me convient je suis
entourée d'eau libre de mes boules que
j'aime sont des boules que j'achète au
cours de mes voyages
quand je tourne c'est la première chose
que je fais ça slash est une boule
chaque fois oui celle-là ça vient
d'argenton sur creuse
je viens de tourner un film et
l'appartement que vous le fasse on vous
le conseille ce que par exemple vous
allez chercher ce qu une chine et non
pas du tout ne fais je pense qu'il est
confortable
il me convient mais au fond voyez
patrice le front de mon caractère je
suis in [ __ ] l endroit où je suis
représente pour moi le confort je pense
que ce n'est pas laid mais au fond je
porte en moi un côté nomade ma maison
c'est c'est moi même je suis très bien
ici mais je peux très bien ailleurs
aussi ce fameux fume-cigarette d'alice
sapritch
raison d'être là l'état 5,4 au
comportement non pas du tout c'est vrai
que je fume beaucoup hélas de plus en
plus et mon fume cigarette c'est quand
même un objet qui qu'ils arrêtent la
nicotine puisque j'ai un filtre je fume
des cigarettes à filtre et j'invite à
l'intérieur et c'est au fond c'est
devenu maintenant une habitude et c'est
presque mon éventail vos livres à yacht
est qu'ils consultent leurs commandes
chacun délivre aussi je suis une
lectrice un peu particulière je veux
dormir dans les nir entourent aide à
l'irs et ce n'est pas pour autant que
jeudi toute la journée
mais je sais qu'ils sont à ma
disposition et je lis d'une façon à
bâtons rompus mettant si vous gravissez
encore quelques échelons disons non à la
popularité box-office dit dre est ce que
vous chantez appartement je ne crois pas
comme je voulais dit toute possession
est une servitude et je veux être libre
non je ne je ne pense pas même si
j'étais une star de cinéma même si je
gagne beaucoup d'argent même si vous
voyez je suis superstitieuse parce que
rien ne me dit que je l'aï dre tant
d'argent
je garderai toujours cet appartement qui
me plaît beaucoup
voler le téléphone sonne parce que il
est il est à mon image
j'aime être à la campagne à paris j'ai
un jardin
je profite du jardin de mes voisins il
est à la fois dans le centre de paris et
isolée en fond il me convient
une lettre bien pour moi je n'aime pas
la parra ne sais pas c'est pas du tout
dans mes goûts
hier soir j'avais un ami j'aime beaucoup
qui est très riche qui aime qui a le
goût de la parra il voyage avec tout son
argent trier des malles entières
je dois dire qu'il en a les moyens il
m'amusais beaucoup mangent aux mesures
oui oui oui d'accord avec city c'est ça
pour dimanche soir oui de kobe fille
jeanne typique je vais parler de lui
aussi c'est gérard oury qui m'a fait de
comscore pourquoi c'est pas parce que je
suis une table qu'on m'appelle quand je
n'étais pas star ou enfin je suis pas je
pense pas que c'est à cause de ça c'est
parce que où ce sont des amis ou ses
pourra faire quand vous êtes chez vous
comme aujourd'hui ce qu'il y à un rituel
dans le déroulement de votre journée ça
se passe comment d'abord je me
déshabille tout de suite je rentre chez
moi c'est à dire que je mets un peignoir
très confortable je prends un bain et
j'ai me mets en peignoir c'est très
exceptionnel que je vous reçois en vue
peut-être recevoir un pays moi je
l'espace non pas du tout mais enfin je
trouve que c'est un peu
un peu trop familier de recevoir un pays
soir je me mets donc en peignoir et je
suis bramois assises je m'installe très
confortablement allongé sur un divan
je lis c'est à un plaisir pour moi
d'être entouré de livres de cigarettes
de mon poste de radio et de monter les
fans si on nous bloque porte la
garde-robe de dice apprécié on y trouve
au genre de tenues les choses très
confortable très simple encore une fois
rédactrice chez vous ça ça correspond à
ce que je vous ai dit tout à l'heure
professionnellement je suis
naturellement obligé d'avoir ce qu'on
appelle une garde robe de comédienne
cette garde robe je lai évidemment j'ai
une des robes du soir j'ai détenu un peu
plus sophistiquée bon mais tout ça comme
les bijoux tout ce qui est extérieur à
l'être humain m'intéresse à dose
homéopathique je ne suis pas ce qu'on
appelle une femme coquette
je n'ai jamais je n'ai jamais travaillé
dans la vie pour plaire écoutez bien ce
que je vais vous dire moi c'est très
important pour plaire d'une façon
artificielle à l'homme à l'homme navale
être humain en face de moi il faut que
les gens axe m'accepte terre que je suis
avec mes défauts et mes défauts ne sur
mon visage avec ce que je suis mais
l'artifice ne m'intéresse pas tellement
ce que vous avez besoin de vous vous
regarder vivre dans une classe à mourenx
j'ai horreur de ça et croyez moi les
moments les plus pénibles de ma journée
c'est quand on au maquis j'ai fini par
en prendre l'habitude mais
je déteste aller chez le coiffeur à
cause de ça parce qu'être devant une
glace avec des bigoudis sous des casques
et se regarder dans une glace
sam est très pénible vous apprenez vos
rôles dans cette chambre et sur se lire
oui tous mes personnages sortent de
cette petite porte
je dis bien ils sortent de cette petite
pas car en principe le travail que je
fais dans cette chan et le travail le
plus important quand je suis sur le
plateau mon travail consiste simplement
à prendre les places que le metteur en
scène me donne et à me donner quelques
indications définitive mais en principe
on travaille se fait d'abord seul ici
j'apprends le rôle et ensuite le
personnage commence à bouger
j'appelle bouger il quitte la position
horizontale pour pour être verticale et
pour marcher je vois le personnage
marché c'est très important pour moi
parce que c'est dans la démarche que je
trouve le mouvement intérieur du
personnage
à ce moment là quand le personnage est
bien en moi le dernier travail consiste
à avoir mon metteur en scène en face de
moi comme vous l'êtes
à ce moment là je lui dis voilà pierre
dargent sites insolites on se sait ça
passe comme ça
pierre cardinal est mon ami jean louis
borie monde en équipe comme on dit ils
viennent là vous voyez que j'ai une
façon particulière de travailler et à ce
moment là je leur dis voilà voilà
comment je conçois de personnages est ce
que vous êtes d'accord
à ce moment la borie me dit oui mais man
se dans ce passage je voudrais un peu
plus aussi un peu moins cela ils partent
et je recommence un autre travail qui
est le travail définitive dans ma tête à
ce moment là laurent les prêts il est
habillé il marche et je vous le propose
donc c'est sûr sony connaissent tous les
personnages de l'essonne absolument
absolument savoureux important et
beaucoup de parfums aussi attirés par
les iphone tout à l'heure je vous ai dit
que je n'étais pas collectionneur mais
c'est une petite manie quand même
j'adore les parfums et tous les parfums
parce que je ne mets jamais un seul
parfum jeu mais plusieurs passages
arrange à ma façon
mon propre parti quand vous êtes comme
ça et dans les soviétiques vous regardez
pas la fenêtre
quel est votre pensée la plus fréquente
regardez le teaser
que peut-il vous répondent d'abord vous
voyez ce que je bois
ces arbres pour le moment il n'y a pas
de feuille et je vous que je suis bien
quelle est la propriété à la campagne
qui me donnerait cette joie d'être au
centre de paris au coeur de paris et
d'être à la campagne ça c'est une chance
que j'apprécie je déteste les propriétés
je n'en ai pas je ne crois pas que j'en
aurai mais par contre être dans le
centre de paris à deux pas de mes amis
de mes bistrot que j'aime vous les
connaissez être là avec mon téléphone
être à trois minutes du centre de tout
ce qui se passe dans le monde entier
et quand je dis le monde entier
c'est-à-dire au coeur de paris ça ça me
plaît beaucoup c'est un luxe et mon seul
luxe
est ce que vous êtes saturation général
aux ans on note une femme soldat corbeil
s'est pas tout à fait exact
je ne suis pas tout à fait seul dans la
vie puisque vous voyez ce tableau ce
tableau à une histoire c'est le tableau
de ma petite nièce qui presque ma fille
car je ne vois pas de différence entre
quelqu'un qu'on aime je n'ai pas le sens
de la maternité
c'est une fille que j'aime parce que
elle me plaît tel quel et j'espère
qu'elle me décevra pas elle choisit une
carrière un métier très dur c'est à dire
la peinture mais je n'ai pas le droit de
décourager car hélas si c'est une
passion je veux être l'élément de sa
passion et je veux les délais je vous
avais très peur que les gens voter soit
parce que vous avez peur de décevoir les
jambes
bien sûr bien sûr c'est même mon premier
souci de ne pas décevoir les êtres
humaines on n'y arrive pas toujours mais
je m'y efforce et ceux qui vous aiment
pas monsieur pour le souvenir en facile
je suis quelqu'un de très orgueilleux
c'est qu'il ne m'aime pas je ne les aime
pas ici dans cet appartement nous avons
vu une comédienne une femme personnages
on nous qui vous avez vu alice et
j'aimerais que vous aimiez c'est al
islah telle qu'elle est avec ses grands
défauts et ses petites qualité